I don't think it's porn it doesn't as  reporters were interested in topics that  touch on the culture and community of  the Internet  follow us as we uncover fascinating  truths of who we are as a society in the  u.s. ready to open up its first safe  injection space men's rights activists  advocate for men's rights because they  feel like women are taking them away how  did you get involved in survivalism as a  lifestyle that's where f revivalist  comes in to help people of color to  start preparing how do you define  yourself either  p she or he my genders intersects what  happens if you can manipulate the  president's face it kind of like it kind  of freaked me out honestly today culture  is something that's shaped by the  internet we need to understand the  difference between a sex worker and a  trafficking victim this is America and  2018 I don't know if that was the worst  thing I've ever done or the better it  could have been both  you  you